- [Instructor] In many videos
when we've discussed evolution
and natural selection, we've
talked about how variation
in a population can fuel
natural selection and evolution.
So if you have a population of circles,
obviously a very simple model here,
maybe some of these circles
are that off-white color,
maybe some of them are blue,
and maybe some of them
are this salmon color.
For certain traits, your environment
might make certain of them
better for reproduction,
better for survival, evading predators,
better for finding food.
Now let's say these circles
for whatever reason,
they're in an environment
where maybe being blue
makes it a little bit
easier to evade predators
and a little bit easier to
reproduce and find food.
Well then, in the next generation,
in the next generation,
because the blue's more likely to be able
to get to reproduction,
because they weren't eaten,
you're likely to have more blues.
So we draw a few more blues.
And maybe a little bit
less of the other ones,
because they're also
competing for resources
amongst each other, at least
in this model that I'm doing.
And so over time, if this blue phenotype,
remember, phenotype is the expressed trait
that's actually observable,
versus a genotype,
which is the overlying
genetics, which is sometimes
observable and sometimes
not, but as you can see,
if in this environment,
blue seems to carry
some advantage, even if it's a slight
probabilistic advantage,
over many generations,
blue will start to dominate.
And so you start to see that
evolution of this population
to being more blue as a species.
So, you have these blue circles.
One way to think about
it is, you have variation
in a species is really
what natural selection
is based off of.
Certain variants might be
more favorable than others,
so that is what's really
necessary for natural selection
to fuel evolution.
To fuel evolution.
Now, a key question is,
where does this variation
in a population come from?
And to think about that, we
just have to remind ourselves
where our phenotypes come from.
How do these expressed
traits get expressed?
Well, in all the living
organisms we're aware of,
we have DNA.
As human beings we have
23 pair of chromosomes,
and each chromosome you can view
as just a very very
very long strand of DNA,
and sections of that DNA
code for various traits,
and each of those sections that code for,
say a certain protein
or a part of an enzyme,
we call those things genes.
We call those things genes.
We have multiple chromosomes.
As human beings, different
species have a different number,
but as human beings we have
23 pair of chromosomes.
Each chromosome you view
as a long strand of DNA.
Parts of that DNA code for specific genes,
and then if you were to zoom in,
if you were to zoom in on those genes,
you would see those nucleotide sequences,
and this is all a review.
We've seen this in other videos,
where you see your adenine, your guanine,
your cytosine, your thiamine,
in order that carries the information
that will eventually be coded into MRNA,
which then gets coded into protein.
Now there's two primary
sources of variation.
One source of a variation
is sexual reproduction.
Sexual reproduction.
Now, not all organisms reproduce sexually,
but many of the ones that we know,
including human beings, do,
where a male member of the species
and a female member of the species
each contribute a random
half of their chromosomes
to the next organism.
So one way to think about
sexual reproduction is
it keeps shuffling the
different versions of the genes
that you have in the population
into different combinations
of those versions of genes, and
so that generates variation.
But sexual reproduction
by itself will not create
new versions of genes,
which we call alleles,
or new genes entirely,
and so the primary way
that that happens is through mutations,
and you might have guessed
that we were gonna talk
about that, 'cause I
had this title up here.
So, another source of variation,
and you could almost view
this as a more fundamental one
because this would
happen even in organisms
that aren't reproducing sexually,
is that over time, there
can be just random mistakes.
There could be edits to these genes,
and it could be a random, maybe this G
gets turned into a C randomly,
or maybe this T and A gets cut out
during the DNA replication process.
These mutations, which
are all about genotype,
and let me make this very clear,
so when we're looking at the sequence,
we're thinking about genotype.
Differences in genotype
are not always obvious
from expressed traits.
Sometimes they do change phenotype
where they're observable in phenotype.
Sometimes they're not.
But when they are observable in phenotype,
as I just mentioned,
many times it could be
a negative change in phenotype
where it makes it less
viable for that organism
or it's harder for them
to survive and reproduce,
but every now and then it could result
in a variation in phenotype
that is maybe neutral
or even confers some type of advantage.
So it might have been a random mutation
that somehow turned one
of these white circles
into a blue circle, and
there might have been
another mutation that
turned a white circle
into a square, and that
just wasn't even viable
as an organism, but the blue circles
happened to be, in the
environment they're in,
happened to be a favorable variation.